[Musique]
bonjour depuis le 7 octobre nos esprits
et nos cœurs sont tournés vers le Proche
Orient le 7 octobre c'est l'épouvantable
attentat du Hamas dans le sud d'Israël
avec
ses ces ces assassinats atroces etes
tortures ces enlèvements dramatiques
enfants de femmes de nourrisson de
vieillards et puis c'est aussi la ripost
musclée c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire
de l'État hébreu qui va entraîner à Gaza
qui va entraîner à son tour son cortège
de milliers de victimes collatérales des
opérations militaires alors est-ce qu'on
peut essayer
d'analyser ce conflit non pas de manière
froide qui pourrait être froide devant
une telle tragédie mais de manière
raisonnable rationnelle rigoureuse c'est
ce que nous allons essayé de faire en
essayant de
de donner à ces de comprendre les causes
profondes de ces événements et de voir
quelles sont les perspectives futures
durables bienvenue dans élémentaire
l'émission de Public Sénat qui cherche à
mettre en perspective et à donner de la
profondeur de champ aux éléments de
l'actualité nous avons intitulé cette
première émission israël-pestine une
guerre de 100 ans et pour nous éclairer
j'ai invité Jean-Paul chagnolo bonjour
bonjour professeur des universités en
sciences politiques directeur de
l'Institut de recherche et d'études
Méditerranées Moyen-Orient vous avez
publié de nombreux livres sur le sujet
qui nous occupe dont le plus récent est
un atlas du Moyen-Orient et puis Gilles
kpel bonjour bonjour vous êtes vous
aussi professeur d'université vous êtes
l'un des meilleurs spécialistes de
l'islam radical vous avez vous aussi
publié de nombreux ouvrages marquants et
le dernier en date prophète en son pays
et le passionnant récit de votre
parcours intellectuel qui n'a pas été de
tout repos dans lequel vous avez été
confronté à une certaine adversité et
d'abord celle de vos pères nous allons
commencer si vous voulez bien avec vous
Jean-Paul chagnolo et nous allons
essayer de voir quelles sont les racines
du du conflit je voudrais simplement
faire un petit rappel historique pour
nos téléspectateur donc il y a une
présence juive en Palestine depuis 1500
ans avant Jésus-Christ présence qui
s'est exprimé dans un ou des états Juifs
jusqu'à peu près au 1er siècle de notre
ère et puis ensuite euh après la
conquête par les Romains les Juifs ont
été dispersés dans le monde et il a
fallu attendre le 19e siècle pour que
naisse au moment où partout émergeit où
se développait l'idée nationale un
projet de foyer national d'État national
en Palestine d'État Juif et un projet de
remigration au début du 20e siècle il y
avait euh 10 à 20000 Juifs en Palestine
après la guerre 14 ils sont 100000 euh
la Palestine est alors sous mandat
britannique il y a la déclaration
Balfour qui donne la perspective d'un
d'un foyer
national 45 après 45 après la chois qui
accélère si j'ose le processus de
création de cet État juif c'est la
décision de l'ONU de la partition de la
Palestine en deux zones l'une arabe et
l'autre juif il y a alors à peu près
600000 Juifs en Palestine simplement
l'idée de du sionisme l'idée un peuple
sans terre les Juifs pour une terre sans
peuple la Palestine il faut
elle est fausse parce qu'il y a en
Palestine à l'époque de la partition
1300000 arabes 90 % sont musulmans et 10
% sont chrétiens et c'est donc plutôt
une seule terre pour deux peuples d'où
VI va venir le conflit qui nous occupe
aujourd'hui je voudrais qu'on essaie de
parcourir cette histoire et d'analyser
les causes de ce conflit en trois dates
la première qui sont à chaque chaque
fois les symptômes d'un des facteur du
du conflit première date 48 donc en 47
l'ONU sépare la Palestine en deux zone
c'est la création de l'État juif les
États arabes voisins attaquent les
jeunes état Hébreux celui-ci gagne mais
ce qui ressort à l'évidence c'est le
refus par les États arabes par l'opinion
publique arabe et par les
Palestiniens de l'existence même d'un
État juif sur cette terre en fait vous
avez vous-même très bien résumé les
choses en disant que c'est un conflit
qu' a un siècle et donc l'affaire se nou
vraiment pendant l'époque du mandat
britannique c'est-à-dire à partir de
1922 le moment où effectivement on
envisage un foyer national juif en
Palestine et il y a une immigration
juive mais qui est une immigration assez
faible au début dans les années 20 elle
devient importante pour des raisons
évidentes à partir des années 30 est
entendu que l'immigration juive d'Europe
elle va de la fin du 19e siècle au début
du 20e aux États-Unis ou ailleurs mais
pas beaucoup en Palestine en tout cas
c'est là que se cristallise à la fois le
nationalisme sioniste on va dire et le
nationalisme palestinien et dès ce
moment-là dès les années 30 il y a a un
affrontement et c'est de là que tout
part c'est les années 30 36 37 et le
premier partage c'est 1937 que proposent
les Britanniques et donc évidemment si
on saute pour aller dans votre dans
votre calendrier dans dans votre schéma
si on arrive à 48 qu'est-ce qui se passe
il se passe qu'une bonne partie de
l'élite palestinienne a disparu dans
cette guerre civile de 36 37 38 et qu'au
fond ils ont pratiquement ils sont
sortis de l'histoire pour plein de
raisons que j'ai pas le temps d'évoquer
ici et il reste au moment de la création
de l'État d'Israël le 14 mai 1948 au
fond un conflit qui va devenir très vite
un conflit israello-arabe et d'ailleurs
les premiers vainqueurs de cette guerre
de 48 c'est Israël évidemment qui va
avoir un territoire plus important que
celui prévu par le plan de partage de 47
mais c'est aussi la trans-jordanie qui
va annexer la S Jordanie qui était la
partie importante de ce qui était
supposé être l'état arabe de Palestine
et Gaza va devenir sous administration
égyptienne donc voilà et donc les les
Palestiniens disparaissent on en parle
plus et le même le mot palestinien ne ne
réapparaîtra que bien longtemps temps PL
tard je vous arrête parce que je
voudrais donc il y a un premier premier
élément c'est le le l'existence d'État
d'Israël pour des raisons qui sont tout
à fait explicables au moins au départ
refusé par le monde arabe
eu il y a il y a un deuxième moment et
on a vu ça encore récemment quand quand
dans les manifestations ce ce sentiment
existe encore on a vu ces manifestations
on criait la Palestine du Jourdain à la
mer c'est-à-dire effaçant l'État
d'Israël mais il y a de l'autre côté une
deuxème date un deuxème sujet qui est
aussi épineux
1967 Israël déclenche une guerre
préemptif contre la menace d'une guerre
des pays arabes voisins c'est la guerre
des 6 jours et conquierre des
territoires qui avaient été attribués
par la partition de 48 aux Arabes elle
conquière ce qu'on appelle la sjordanie
elle conquièt Gaza elle conquère le
Sinaï elle conquierèt le golane elle va
rendre une partie de ces au fur et à
mesure des années elle va rendre le
Sinaï à l'Égypte elle va rendre le Golan
à la Syrie elle va rendre Gaza dans les
conditions qu'on va évoquer ensuite
reste la S Jordanie à Jérusalem et
l'occupation de ces territoires la
création de colonies juives dans ces
territoires est comme un poison qui va
exacerber l'hostilité des Palestiniens à
la perspective d'une paix avec les
Israéliens si vous me permettez il faut
là encore revenir un peu en arrière
parce que les Palestiniens dont je viens
de dire qu'ils avaient pratiquement
disparu de l'histoire entre 194 38 et
1967 on ne parle pas de conflit
israël-palestinien on parle d'un conflit
israëlo-arabe d'un conflit interétatique
et en fait il y a une lente réémergence
du nationalisme palestinien qui surgit
après la guerre de 77 et dans les
conclusions dans les effets de la guerre
de 67 il y a évidemment ce que vous avez
dit c'està-dire l'occupation de la
sjouranie Jérusalem est inclu et de Gaza
mais il y a aussi le fait que le
nationalisme arabe s'écroule
véritablement en asser a perdu et pas
simplement naer c'est toute l'idéologie
qui ensevelissait toute forme d'autres
idéologie et en particulier le
nationalisme palestinien et entre 68 et
et les années qui vont suivre le
nationalisme palestinien ressurgit avec
force et la création de l'OLP qui était
créée déjà en 64 mais qui va devenir une
organisation vraiment palestinienne à
partir de 68 69 et donc là le le le
conflit se prolonge autrement cette
fois-ci où des Palestiniens sont sous
occupation israélienne et par rapport à
ce que vous venez de dire sur la
colonisation effectivement euh ce n'est
pas simplement une occupation militaire
simplement entre guillemets mais il y a
en plus dès les années on va dire 70 et
ça va s'accélérer après 77 une
colonisation c'est-à-dire la volonté en
particulier de la droite israélienne de
prendre ces terres au maximum parce
qu'il considèrent que ce sont les terres
juives et que par conséquent il est pas
question de compromis politique il est
pas question de rétrocession au
Palestiniens et ça c'est un des grands
enjeux jusqu'au moment en un mot encore
où dans les années 87 88 le nationalisme
palestinien arrive de manière si forte
si évidente qu'il faut bien trouver un
compromis et on arrive dans la foulée
après beaucoup d'événements on va très
vite on va arriver sur la une date clé
qui est c'est la trè date c'est celle
que vous allez donner exactement c'est
la 3è date que j'avais retenu parce que
je me disais 48 l'hostilité des arabes à
l'existence deisraël 67 le poison des
colonisations qui attise c'est d'abord
le pron de l'occupation de l'occupation
et de la colonisation qui attise la
renqueur des palestinens la guerre
d'Israël et puis 93 cependant lueur
d'espoir les accords d'Oslo la fameuse
poignée de main célèbre entre difficile
entre Arafat et abine sous sous
l'autorité des États-Unis simplement
cette paix là ces accords d'Oslo qui
reconnaissent Israël reconnaît l'OLP
l'OLP reconnaît Israël on crée une
Autorité palestinienne et finalement cet
espoir de de de de paix va va faire
pchite
pourquoi dans toute négociation de cette
importance ce sont des négociations
existentielles pour les uns comme pour
les autres il y a évidemment des
oppositions terrible du côté israélien
il y a une droite et une extrême droite
violemment opposé violemment au point
que certains vont aller jusqu'à
assassiner euh Rabine le 4 novembre 1995
et celui qui est un peu le chef
d'orquestre de cette coalition de droite
qui est vend debout contre les accords
de slow c'est un certain Benjamin
naniaou qui va être élu au début de ce
processus il va être élu en mai 1996 et
il n'aura de cesse que d'essayer de
déstabiliser le processus de et du côté
des Palestiniens ceux qui sont vraiment
également violemment opposés et là il
faut prendre le mot violemment dans tout
sa dimension c'est le Hamas qui en 95 96
j'étais sur place et j'ai vu très
concrètement très presque charnellement
ce que c'était que les attentat
terroristes par exemple un bus qui
explose en plein Jérusalem en plein
jafarud à deux pas de la ville
évidemment c'est ces
forcesl ont fait en sorte que ce ce
processus il y a bien d'autes raison a
fait naufrage il faut dire aussi que
faire la paix c'est quelque chose de de
extraordinairement difficile il faut
vraiment des hommes d'État et je crois
que du côté côté israélien il y avait un
homme d'État c'était Rabine alors ça
c'est on a vu avec vous les les causes
profondes mais en effet vous l'avez dit
à la fin des années 80 il se passe un
phénomène et je vais nous allons en
parler tous les deux Gill si vous voulez
bien c'est que le conflit change de
nature d'abord dans un contexte plus
général qui est que le nationalisme
arabe qui avait fait les grandes heures
du monde arabe depuis les années 50
disons jusqu'aux années 80 cède le pas
partout dans le monde arabe au phénomène
de l' islamisme oui et ça se produit en
fait en 1973 lors de la guerre dite du
d'octobre ou du Kipour ou du Ramadan où
les l'offensive arabe prend prétexte de
du jeûe juif du Kipour pour exercer une
surprise et les armées arabes pendant le
ramadan en principe les soldats n'ont
pas le droit de s'alimenter mais les
zouléain qui obéissent au dirigeants
arabes proclam un djihad de manière
parce que le djihad permet de
s'alimenter pendant le jeûne d'urnne et
la victoire arabe de 73 qui était d'une
part la défites surprise et ensuite
malgré la la contreoffensive israélienne
victorieuse parce que les Américains
avaient fait un point aérien c'est
l'embargo sur le pétrole voulu par le
roi feissal d'Arabie Saoudite qui fait
du pétrole une arme politique et à
l'époque l'Arabie Saoudite et
le symbole de l'islamisme triomphant et
ce sont eux qui vont être les porteurs
de la victoire alors que le nationalisme
nassérien avait été le vecteur de la
défaite en 67 et à partir de ce
moment-là que 73 est le moment si vous
voulez du basculement du nationalisme à
la montée en puissance de l'islamisme
dans la région qui ne va faire ensuite
que se développer jusqu'à ce que le
processus de paix commence à se mettre
en place l'expression de l'islamisme
enfin la force qui incarne cet islamisme
dans la région c'est le Hamas c'est lui
qui va porter cette cette perspective
nouvelle dans le conflit
israélo-palestinien et avec un immense
succès et notamment à partir du moment
où il prend le contrôle de Gaza oui
notamment et aussi parce que d'une
certaine manière une partie de
l'establishement d'Israélien qui est
très inquiet du fait que l'OLP c'est le
nationalisme arabe a beaucoup d'écho à
dans le dans le monde va favoriser le
développement du Hamas moi je me
souviens j'étais en Égypte à l'époque je
faisais ma thèse et le Sinaï avait été
rétrocédé à à l'Égypte après sad dat à
l'époque de Sadat j'étais sur le canal
de Sue avec le chargé d'affaires
israélien par hasard on attendait le bac
qui n'arrivait pas à l'époque il y avit
pas de sécurité avec sa femme euh qui
était une juif de Sarcel je me souviens
on commencé à discuter vous faites votre
tè sur les mouvements islamistes très
intéress inessant ce sont des gens avec
qui il faut que nous négocions parce que
ça fait partie du peuple palestinien et
dès ce moment-là vous avez aussi dans la
droite
israélienne un peu comme vous savez on
disait en France j'aime tellement
l'Allemagne que j'en veux deux il était
très bien la division va voilà va
favoriser et ça netanahou a poussé ça à
l'extrême puisque pendant qu'il était au
pouvoir
autrefois le Qatar chaque mois envoyait
un avion plein dollars destiné au Hamas
qui arrivait à l'aéroport bengourion qui
était escorté à la frontière par le
mossade puis ensuite par les services
égyptiens qui distribuaiit aux hôpitaux
et cetera mais aussi au Hamas l'idée
étant que la cocote minute de Gaza si
vous voulez pour qu'elle n'explose pas
parce que vous avez des millions de
personnes dans quelques centaines de
kilomètres carrés c'était l'occasion de
mettre la question proprement
palestinienne comme l'a décrit très bien
Jean-Paul chadul tout à l'heure sous le
tapis au-delà de du jeu complexe et
macavellique des Israéliens comment
expliquez-vous le Hamas prend le pouvoir
à Gaza en 2007 il instaure un régime
autoritaire c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire il il y a plus d'élections les
homosexuels sont pour chassés les femmes
le statut des femmes la charè est misise
en œuvre et puis les les ressources
financières sont toutes détournées pour
organiser une économie de guerre 25000
requêes sont tirées sur Israël entre
2007 et aujourd'hui des centaines
d'atata des repr
comment expliquez-vous que cette cette
cette mise en coupe réglée dans un
objectif de mort et désolation et
remporter l'adhésion non seulement d'une
partie des Palestiniens de Gaza mais
apparaisse y compris pour les les
Palestiniens de 6 jordadie comme
l'alternative crédible plutôt que le
plutôt que l'OLP qui était rentré dans
un processus de paix avec Israël parce
que l'OLP était trop affaibli et
discrédité c'est bien le problème et en
partie du fait de la pression des
Israéliens et à Gaza en S Jordanie c'est
différent je pense pas que le que Hamas
est aujourd'hui déjà gagné en
sisjordanie même si la solidarité
aujourd'hui avec Gaza est importante
mais la situation à Gaza est absolument
catastrophique et invable moi j ai fait
cinq missions et effectivement il y a il
y a pas de ressources si vous voulez et
à Gaza ne vivent pas des gens de Gaza ce
sont des gens qui sont rfugés réfugiés
des territoires qui ont été conquis par
Isra ou mais mais mais la vie est
impossible pour une large par du fait
même du Hamas de la façon dont il a géré
cette entité oui alors je ne défends
bien sûr pas le Hamas ici mais la la le
fait que la situation soit tellement
impossible les gens ne vivent que de
leunois pourquoi Gaza a une telle
démographie parce que les nations- Unies
donnent des subsides en fonction des des
enfants que vous avez donc à court terme
vous avez beaucoup d'enfants mais c'est
absolument invivable et de ce fait les
solutions les plus extrémistes
c'est-à-dire le Hamas qui prône la
destruction d'Israël et cetera sont ceux
sont celles qui ont l'écho de la
population qui est prise dans un piège
et ça c'est la situation que nous avons
aujourd'hui et qui est catastrophique il
y a un autre élément de bascule par
rapport à la période initiale don qu'on
a évoqué avec Jean-P chagnolo c'est au
départ la cause palestinienne et soutenu
principalement et les mouvements
palestiniens par les pays arabes sunites
mais apparaît un nouvel acteur dont on a
vu les liens avec Hamas c'est l'Iran en
quoi le le le le le choc Iran Arabie
Saoud ou sunnit a joué un rôle dans
l'exacerbation du conflit PAL par un
grand nombre de pays arabes sunnites
graduellement ont finit par trouver un
modus vivindi avec Israël l'Israël
invincible qui disposait d'une
technologie militaire extraordinaire est
apparu intéressant et c'était le l'enjeu
par exemple du pacte d'Abraham où le
Maroc
pactise parce que en contre-partie les
États-Unis reconnaissent la marocanité
du Sahara espagnol anciennement espagnol
ou occidental mais aussi parce que euh
les Marocains disposent d'armes
ultraperformantes contre les vieux tanks
soviétiques que l'Algérie aligne dans le
Sahara les Émirats grâce à
l'infrastructure militaire et au
software militaire israélien peuvent
mieux se protéger contre l'Iran et de ce
fait euh les Palestiniens se sentant
surtout ceux du Hamas se sentant mis sur
la touche vont se tourner euh vers
l'Iran qui voit dans la Palestine qui
est où le Hamas est un parti sunnite
hein c'est pas un parti chiite et l'Iran
va faire de ce parti sunnite qui est le
Hamas le fer de lance de ce qu'ils
appellent l'axe de la résistance et
aujourd'hui ce que vous avez c'est que
pour la première fois l'Iran à ce point
a réussi à se faire le défenseur des
causes arabes et musulmanes al c'est un
pays qui n'est pas arabe c'est un pays
chiite c'est 15 % de l'ensemble des
musulmans c'est quelque chose qui est
tout à fait important et qui vous
explique explique les repositionnements
aujourd'hui euh la l'objectif pour
l'Iran étant de marginaliser l'Arabie
Saoudite de Mohamed Ben Salman
rappelez-vous que l'attentat enfin le
l'offensive pardon contre Israël le 7
octobre la radia du 7 octobre qui est un
peu un écho de celle du 11 septembre
c'est-à-dire exposer Israël comme un
colos au pied d'argile de même que les
États-Unis étent un colosse au pied
d'argile a eu lieu juste après que deux
ministres israéliens ont été reçus
officiellement pour la première fois en
Arabie Saoudite qu'attend l'Arabie
Saoudite par exemple disposer du dô de
fer israélien qui lui permettrait
d'éviter d'être soumis au missiles
envoyés par les Houtis du Yémen qui sont
fournis par les Iraniens c'est ça et on
le voit aujourd'hui les Houtis sont
utilisés par les Iraniens par exemple
pour envoyer des missiles en mer Rouge
Jean-Paul je voudrais qu'on qu'on qu'on
regarde maintenant qu'est-ce qui peut se
passer je je reviens moi-même de
plusieurs jours en Israël j'ai rencontré
des Israéliens des Palestiniens des
Arabes israéliens et je dois dire que
que le le le le comme me l'a dit l'un de
mes interlocuteurs Palestiniens on est
au point le plus bas de la possibilité
de la paix et j'ai eu l'impression que
mes interlocuteurs doutaient tous de la
possibilité d'une paix à deux États qui
était le la formule à laquelle disIl
seule la France croit encore est-ce
qu'il y a un schéma possible dont on
pourrait encore penser qu'il a qu'il
peut recueillir l'adhésion et créer une
paix une coexistence durable vous savez
quand on on évoque la montée en
puissance du Hamas à partir donc de sa
création 87
88 il y a eu toujours une forme de
d'équilibre dans les influences ou de de
modulation des influences en fonction du
rapport au processus politique de paix
pendant la période d'Oslo c'était très
caractéristique c'estàdire quand on
pensait que il y avait effectivement une
chance qu'on aille vers un vrai un vrai
accord il y a eu des moments très
fugitifs ou tout de même moi j'étais
souvent là-bas à ce moment-là et on
avait le sentiment que ça pouvait
aboutir c'était en en mai 87 16 ou en
2000 enfin bon et et et là le Hamas
reculait et reculait très nettement bien
entendu il continuait il continuait avec
des attentats terroristes pour vraiment
déstabilisé mais je veux dire il faut
bien penser à ça c'estàd que quand on
dit quand Gil Capel à juste titre dit
que l'OLP est décrédibilisée d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui elle a disparu pratiquement
mais c'est l'autorité palestinienne qui
n'est pas l'OLP qui est simplement
l'autorité sur les sur les territoires
et donc une partie du peuple palestinien
alors quep représente l'ensemble du
peuple palestinien et compris ceux qui
sont en exil et bien s'il y a un chemin
politique et bien il est clair que ça ça
peut marginaliser ou en tout cas
affaiblir le Hamas autrement dit je
pense qu'on peut éradiquer le Hamas on B
par la guerre al ça sera un vaste débat
mais par la paix et aujourd'hui
effectivement parler de deux états ça
paraît complètement utopique sauf que
c'est la seule solution alors on peut
imaginer des étapes intermédiaires on
peut imaginer moi je suis partisan de
d'une interposition par exemple d'une
force internationale alors que elles ont
tout échoué mais c'est pas parce
qu'elles ont toujours tout échoué tout
le temps échoué que il faut pas
réessayer autrement dit s'il y a pas un
investissement de de la communauté
internationale aujourd'hui dans cette
perspective avec un horizon politique
comme a dit Joe Biden et bien on va vers
vers des souffrances et des et des
dévastations terrible Gill vous vous
imaginez que comme c'est arrivé dans
d'autres mouvements historiques que le
Hamas ou que l'Iran aujourd'hui
fanatiquement hostile à toute paix
dramatiquement orienté vers la mort
plutôt que vers la vie et vers la
destruction vers plutôt que vers la
construction vous pensez que
historiquement ils peuvent bouger vous
pensez que le H et l'Iran peuvent
devenir des interlocuteurs d'une ou en
tout cas les forces qu'elle représentent
du de de les acteurs de de d'une paix
deain et est-ce que inversement est-ce
qu'on peut on peut éradiquer
militairement le Hamas mais est-ce qu'on
peut l'éradiquer politiquement et
intellectuellement de la tête des
Palestiniens de ceux qui le soutiennent
je ne crois pas que dans la situation
actuelle ce soit le Hamas qui soit en
position de décision de décision de quoi
que ce soit l'enjeu c'est c'est l'Iran
c'est l'Iran
qui aujourd'hui est en train d'essayer
de remodeler la situation au
Moyen-Orient à son avantage face à
l'Arabie Saoudite et les Palestiniens
dans cette affaire sont l'instrument de
la politique iranienne et en particulier
le Hamas qui n'a qu'une assez faible
marge de décision j'ai bien vu que les
renseignements américains mais bon on
peut pas dire qu'ils ont été très forts
ces temps-ci ont dit à leurs collègues
européens que c'est pas du tout l'Iran
c'est le Hamas mais ça c'est ce que veut
entendre monsieur Biden et si on veut
nous faire croire euh la question
actuelle c'est la redistribution des
forces dans la région et avec la radia
du 7 octobre 2023
50 ans exactement après la guerre du
Ramadan et du Kipour l'objectif était
d'affaiblir significativement Israël
d'affaiblir de ce fait les pays arabes
sunnites dont les gouvernements avaient
pactisé avec Israël puisqueaujourd'hui
est-ce que vous êtes un un gouver
gouvernement arabe est-ce que vous
pensez que finalement les armes
israéliennes sont invincibles non d'où
la volonté de d'Israël et de son actuel
gouvernement dirigé par Monsieur
netaniaahou qui quand même pose un
énorme problème comment est-ce que la
guerre peut être menée par celui-là même
ni la situation actuelle c'est un c'est
un un problème majeur euh ils sont
obligés de mener de leur point de vue à
eux hein de la l'offensive pour
retrouver une crédibilité militaire y
compris face à leurs interlocuteurs ce
qui est une sorte de catch 22 parce que
cette crédibilité militaire elle ne
peut-être retrouvée qu'au prix de
victimes civiles en un nombre tel que
l'opinion va se retourner tous les gens
qui ont été même en Occident horrifiés
par les images qu'on a vu du 7 octobre
et encore on a vu en Europe à la
télévision des images floutées donc ça
c'est un c'est le problème qui se qui se
pose aujourd'hui mais remarquez quand
même j'ai dis juste un tout petit mot
c'est que l'offensive militaire
israélienne et graduelle c'est-à-dire
que elle s'accompagne de négociation
aujourd'hui euh les vrais enjeux c'est à
Qatar c'est à Qatar que résident les
patrons du Hamas c'est à Qatar que se
fait l'intermédiation
entre Turquie et Iran entre Arabie
Saoudite et Iran entre Amérique et Iran
entre Israël et Iran et c'est là que les
vraies choses se jouent le d'une
certaine manière les Palestiniens euh
malheureusement sont aujourd'hui et en
particulier le mass instrumentalisé par
des forces qui les dépassent c'est
peut-être là que réside la solution
justement je sais pas ce qu'en pense
Jean-Paul chagnolo mais je crois que
c'est plutôt à dans dans le dans le
système global que nous aurons des
mouvements qui vont changer la situation
sur le terrain mais je livre cette
hypothèse à votre réponse à votre
sagacité notre émission s'achève elle
s'achève moi je dirais que c'est une
lecture par l'extérieur qui a évidemment
sa sa pertinence mais il faut ne pas pas
négliger une lecture par l'intérieur et
la dimension nationale palestinienne
elle est très forte et je crois que ce
qui vient de se passé pendant toutes ces
dernières années on a vraiment mis comme
vous le disiez la question palestinen
sous le tapis mais c'est pas possible
les Palestiniens ont forcément surgi par
la violence moi je pensais que ça
viendrait de la 6anie il y a eu beaucoup
de choses ces deux trois dernières
années c'est venu par Gaza et dans des
conditions que j'avais pas imaginé
évidemment mais je pense qu'il y a une
autonomie de de l'histoire palestinienne
et par conséquent aussi une autonomie
relative de des Palestiniens et que
l'issue moi je le vois beaucoup moins en
Iran que aux États-Unis parce que c'est
eux qui ont la clé et d'abord en faisant
en sorte qu'il y a une trêve humanitaire
le plutôt possible parce que sinon on va
aller on est à 9000 morts et on y sera à
15000 dans quelques jours autrement dit
ça sera mortifire pour absolument tout
le monde ça sera vraiment une guerre où
tout le monde aura perdu comme me le
disait l'un des interurs que j'ai
rencontré un Israélien homme homme
d'affaire d'un investisseur israélien il
disait l'histoire nous montre que chaque
drame de notre relation Israël au
palestinienne de chaque drame est né
finalement euh dans la douleur la
conscience que l'autre existait qu'il
fallait qu'on s'entende avec lui c'est
un message d'espoir je ne sais pas si
sera réalisé merci merci à tous les deux
de nous avoir éclairé cette émission
s'achève j'espère que nous vous avons
donné des élément de d'intelligence de
la situation au Proche Orient dont nous
espérons qu'elle va quand même à la fin
connaître des perspectives plus
heureuse merci de nous avoir suivi et à
très
vite
e